yesterday was the 50-year anniversary of
president nixon
taking the united states off the gold
standard now most people don't know
exactly what that means and they may
have heard that there was actually two
different times that we went off the
gold standard what actually happened was
in 1933
when you hear that we were taken off the
gold standard what it means is that the
us government required everyone who had
gold whether they're gold coins or other
types of gold to come in and to
contribute them to give them to the
government it became illegal to own gold
the reason why they did that was the us
government wanted to drastically
increase the gold reserves that they
held they were worried about inflation
and a number of other things and so by
doing that what they forced was everyone
to give their gold up and to adopt the
u.s dollar and to adopt the u.s coins
in doing so now that the us had very
deep gold reserves they were able to
reprice the gold how well they just said
it's worth more and they repriced it to
about i think 35 so if i remember
correctly by doing that they were able
to increase the monetary supply and so
when you look at the first time that you
may hear the u.s went off the gold
standard what that means is people who
had gold had to give their gold into the
government that does not mean what
happened later in 1971 which was 50
years ago yesterday in 1971 there was a
number of issues that the country was
facing and
president nixon on a sunday night went
on television and here is the exact
words i do not want anyone to say that
we don't go do our research and pull up
the exact quote of what richard nixon
said so to start he said
one of the cruelest legacies of the
artificial prosperity produced by war is
inflation
inflation robs every american every one
of you the 20 million who are retired
and living on fixed incomes they are
particularly hard hit homemakers find it
harder than ever to balance the family
budget and 80 million american wage
earners have been on a treadmill for
example in the four war years between
1965 and 1969 your wage increases were
completely eaten up by price increases
your paychecks were higher but you were
no better off we have made progress
against the rise in the cost of living
from the high point of six percent a
year in 1969 the rise in consumer prices
has been cut to 4
in the first half of 1971. but just as
the case in our fight against
unemployment we can and we must do
better than that the time has come for
decisive action action that will break
the vicious circle of spiraling prices
and cost now that sounds a lot like
today they're talking about six down to
four percent consumer price increases in
the first half of 1971 but the president
continued with his quote he said
i am today ordering a freeze on all
prices and wages throughout the united
states for a period of 90 days in
addition i call upon corporations to
extend the wage price freeze to all
dividends working together we will break
the back of inflation and we will do it
without the mandatory wage and price
controls that crush economic and
personal freedom
in the past seven years there has been
an average of one international monetary
crisis every year now who gains from
these crises not the working man not the
investor not the real producers of
wealth the gainers are the international
money uh money speculators because they
thrive on crisis they help to create it
and then finally he moved on to the big
boy part of the speech
he said in recent weeks the speculators
have been waging an all-out war on the
american dollar the strength of a
nation's currency is based on the
strength of that nation's economy and
the american economy is by far the
strongest in the world accordingly i've
directed the secretary of the treasury
to take the action necessary to defend
the dollar against the speculators i
have directed secretary canali to
suspend temporarily the convertibility
of the dollar into gold or other reserve
assets except in amounts and conditions
determined to be in the interest of
monetary stability and in the best
interest of the united states august 15
1971.
now when you read this there's a lot of
similarities to what's going on today
high rates of inflation there's worry
about speculators in the market and
there is a belief that intervening in
the market will be the solution but what
we know is that when this decision was
made in august 15 of
1971
president nixon his administration and
those advisors who told him to do this
could not have foreseen what was to
happen next there's actually quotes on
record where people said honestly we
don't know what's going to happen they
were taking a best guess as to what they
should do but when they unpegged the us
dollar from gold meaning that you could
no longer take that dollar and go and
redeem it for gold at the bank or at a
vault
that gave the united states the power to
print as much money as they deemed fit
they could increase or contract the
money supply in order to respond to
economic instability sounds like a great
idea theoretically but here is the truth
here is the hard facts as to what has
occurred since that decision in 1971 the
growth in productivity and hourly
compensation has absolutely bifurcated
what that means is that in 1971 what we
saw was a plus
250 percent or more increase in
productivity but compensation has barely
budged productivity took off
compensation went sideways
if we then look at something like real
gdp real wages and trade policies in the
us what we see there is that real gdp
per capita uh per capita absolutely
exploded but in orange there you see the
average real wage has absolutely gone
sideways the real median weekly earnings
of full-time workers has gone
sideways excuse me and so when you see
things like gdp per capita taking off
and all kinds of things like gdp per
full-time employee taking off but wages
going sideways we then can look at the
income gains and whether they were
widely shared or not well before 1971
when rich people made more money
poor people made more money when the
middle class made more money so did the
rich and the poor
all three groups of folks continue to
grow about the same rate but real family
income has absolutely been bifurcated
the 95th percentile of folks those that
are the richest have taken off and
continued on a very similar rate to what
they were doing previously but the
median and the bottom 20th percentile
have gone sideways when you destroy
the value of the money by debasing it
because you can print as much as you
want what you do is you hurt the bottom
50 percent or so of your population and
you enrich the wealthy don't believe me
here is the income growth from 1917 to
2012.
what we can see is that up until 1971
the bottom 90 of earners had much much
much higher income growth than the top 1
of earners since then the top one
percent of earners have gone on an
absolute tear but the bottom 90 of
earners have gone sideways they actually
have even dropped some in that income
growth not good if we continue and we
look at the share of gross domestic
income for the compensation of employees
you can see a 50-year decline in wages
that are the share of the economy's
total income for 50 years it has gone
off a cliff i should mention all of
these charts come from an awesome
website called what
wtf happened in 1971. wtf happened in
1971 the arrows are 1971. the next chart
income share top 1 relative to the
bottom 90
what you can see is that after 1971 the
income share of the top one percent
exploded compared to the bottom 90 the
rich got richer and the poor got poorer
well how
much has life changed well in 1971
here's the cost of living wild
statistics on this one a new house costs
25
200
the average income was 10
622
the new car would cost about 3 500 bucks
and average rent was 150 per month movie
tickets dollar fifty gasoline 40 cents
per gallon wanted to mail something
postage stamp was eight cents these
numbers look absurd compared to today
today there are people in america paying
three four five dollars for a gap for a
gallon of gasoline it used to be 40
cents tuition to harvard if you are a
harvard man you used to only pay 2 600
per year
today you pay upwards of 60 70 80 000
there is immense inflation and impact in
the cost of living
let's look at campbell's condensed
tomato soup that sounds like a great one
what the hell happened in 1971
it went sideways for decades
and then it decided to absolutely
explode
this tomato soup can also hide the
effects of inflation by shrinking while
keeping the same price but you're still
seeing these high rates of price growth
and then lastly let's just look at
cumulative inflation that seems to be a
great one to end on from 1913 to 2015
we're just going up baby we're gonna
just go up and to the right it looks
like a chart
that masa draws and puts unicorns on and
says my 300 year plan we're ready to
rock and roll that's what that chart
looks like it is bonkers and so
ultimately what we have is 50 years
after we went off the gold standard and
we gave the government here in the
united states and elsewhere the ability
to leverage fiat currencies we have seen
an explosion
in the cost of living but we have not
seen the exact same increase in wages
which means you are worse off today in
purchasing power terms than you were
back then on top of that from a wage
perspective you also have the investor
perspective if your family was to have
made any money and in 1971 put a hundred
dollars in the bank and simply hold it
that hundred dollars can buy nowhere
near what it could have bought in 1971
that is the erosion of purchasing power
and so we have gone from a society where
your great grandparents and your
grandparents told your parents or
yourself save
savers can get wealthy you can save your
way to financial security that is no
longer true in this country the only way
to protect your purchasing power the
only way to achieve financial security
and the only way to get actual financial
freedom is you have to learn to invest
saving is for losers as my friend robert
kiyosaki always says the only way to
build true wealth is you have to be an
investor you have to learn how to
convert dollars into assets whether
they're equities commodities bitcoin or
something else you have to learn how to
protect that purchasing power because
the dollar is being devalued every
single one of those charts i just showed
you was before the historic debasement
of the currency over the last 18 months
as well so things are only getting worse
how many people do we think
actually know those charts and
understand how bad this has been since
1971. very few people yep very few yeah
i mean this is something that we should
talk about every single day right like
the general idea behind it was that the
global gold supply uh would would
increase at a small rate every single
year right just a small rate because the
supply was constrained but the idea was
that that would keep our overspending in
check inflation in check etc so the idea
that we would come off this the results
should have been known and they were
known i mean he talked about it in the
speech president nixon government has
become too cavalier about borrowing and
printing money right so when you think
about uh us now us debt the total level
we went from at the time in 1971 we had
like three or four hundred billion
dollars of u.s debt now we're up to over
28 29 trillion dollars so that's just
gone incredible right and then uh from
an inflation perspective we're up over
five percent this year it's totally
separated the wealth inequality gap and
and continue to expand that within this
country and we just looked at a bunch of
the charts you look at how it's impacted
the top one percent of earners in this
country versus literally everyone else
especially the bottom uh 50 25 10 etc
it's put them in a hole that's
impossible to come out to and now we're
at a point where we're not able to go
back to the gold standard there's uh the
us government reserves it would have to
be 10 to 15 to 20 times the current
price of gold for us
for us to return to that so it's just
brought up the need for sound money like
bitcoin like other stores of value et
cetera the craziest part to me about the
entire 1971 uh example is that there was
two major statements made
one it was done as a defense against
speculators everyone loves when we're
gonna defend ourselves right oh the big
bad boogeyman speculators let's protect
ourselves from them so we're gonna make
a decision it's like when people go to
war and they say it's us first them
everyone wants to rally around it
there's nationalism involved and say
people say yes let's go to war
well when you present this as a way to
protect yourself from the speculators
it's easy to get people to buy in the
second thing is that it was temporary
but 50 years later the temporary period
has not ended it went from temporary to
permanent
now the examples and similarities to
1971 to today there's high rates of
inflation there's high levels of
unemployment and they're telling you
that inflation is temporary as well
i'm not one to say that inflation is
here forever at over five percent but
what i am saying is that we have
accelerated the negative sides of every
single one of these charts over the last
18 months and there's nothing you can do
i can do or anyone else i can't convince
anyone to do anything differently that
it oversees monetary or fiscal policy
but what you can do is you can educate
yourself you can make sure you protect
your wealth hey guys thanks so much for
watching that clip of the best business
show make sure you like and subscribe to
the channel turn on notifications so you
know when we go live every weekday and
then head to sofi.com so that you can
get an account we can get after it